today on the matt well show now that the
cancel mob has started canceling
dead children's authors it's clear that
eventually everybody will be cancelled
unless the madness stops so we'll talk
about that today plus five headlines
including the fbi director suspiciously
refusing to provide any information
about the death of officer siknik plus
texas lifts
all coveted restrictions and joe biden
says that maybe
if we're lucky we can get back to normal
next year
all of that and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know it's bad enough when the cancel
vultures descend on some living person
and start ripping the flesh off their
bones for some perceived offense
whether recent or in the distant past i
hate that kind of cancellation about as
much as a person could possibly hate
anything
but still not as much as i hate the
cancellation of the dead
though you may say it isn't as bad
because at least the person's no longer
around to suffer the mob's wrath
there's still something so just
supremely arrogant and gratuitous about
staging a public show
trial of a guy who's not here to defend
himself and whose sins are being judged
through a modern lens
by people who don't understand and have
no interest in trying to understand
the historical context in which the dead
man lived
but such is the fate of dr seuss as we
discussed briefly yesterday
it began with some schools deciding to
de-emphasize
not ban they say just de-emphasize dr
seuss books
on the grounds that soos had racist
views and some of his books contained
images with racial undertones
then the national education association
according to usa today quote pivoted
from dr seuss to a focus on
diverse children's books next joe biden
broke from presidents trump and obama by
leaving seuss's name out of the national
read across america day proclamation
and finally dr seuss enterprises itself
announced that it would stop publishing
six dr seuss titles
saying that the books contain images and
messages that are quote hurtful and
wrong
now all of this happened in the span of
a few days
dr seuss went from a beloved children's
author
to problematic to pariah in about
48 hours now
if you have a problem with any of this
the media is here to inform you that
you're wrong
and probably stupid an nbc article
published this morning says
critics are condemning a decision to no
longer publish six dr seuss books
but experts say a reckoning with his
racist works is long overdue
well that settles it experts said so
experts on what though who are the
experts that we can call in to settle
the question of whether
uh the cat in the hat is turning our
kids into white supremacists
well nbc explains here are the experts
they say um
uh quote in dr seuss's books we have a
kind of sensibility which is oriented
toward
centering the white child and
de-centering everyone else
said ebony thompson or rather ebony
thomas a professor of children's and
young adult literature at the university
of pennsylvania
she is the author of the dark fantastic
race and the imagination from harry
potter to the hunger games
she continues dr seuss was shaped by a
completely immersive white supremacist
culture
even during that time our ancestors and
elders were protesting racist works and
producing alternative stories for our
children
how do we decide what endures and what
doesn't endure it's our responsibility
to decide
what kind of books to put in front of
our kids
um the debate is a complicated one
because it must tackle the fortitude of
classic books
while reckoning with the place of such
stories in a world of diverse readers
and then it says a 2019 survey of
seuss's works found that just two
percent
of the human characters were people of
color 98
were white um okay well the last
statistic there seems a little bit
odd ninety-eight percent of seuss's
human characters are white and 2
are people of color is it even obvious
who the humans are supposed to be in the
dr seuss book
i mean it's it's it's it's clear where
maybe the human non-human line is drawn
in a story like cat and a hat okay i get
like you got the cat then you got the
kids
but what about green eggs and ham i mean
you tell me
like many seuss characters he appears to
be the main characters here
appear to be some sort of monstrous
human
dog cat alien hybrid
in top hats do the experts put him under
the white umbrella or the person of
color umbrella
is it racist to call the the
green eggs and ham thing white or is it
racist to call it a person of color
these are all questions we must ask now
in a country that has completely lost
its mind now in a sane country we could
just say
who cares it's a children's book
children have been reading this book
for decades without a problem there is
no problem here
we don't need to make a problem where it
doesn't exist yes dr seuss had some
objectional views
yes he drew some offensive pictures at
certain points in his life
who cares none of that interferes with
the child's ability to enjoy a story
about
the sneetches or the who's in whoville
unless you make it interfere and we
shouldn't
now that is what a sane country would
say but again we don't live in that sort
of country anymore
now two additional points here first we
should always keep in mind
amid the current rush to posthumously
cancel historical figures
from presidents all the way down to
children's authors
that none of the hysteria hinges on new
information
it's not as though some series of
breathtaking revelations has come to
light
indiana jones didn't open up a secret
vault in some old temple somewhere
uncovering dark truths about the past of
dr seuss
the canceled mob justifies tearing down
the thomas jefferson statue or taking
abraham lincoln's name off a school or
banning the books of a suddenly
problematic author
and demands that we do it all right now
right this instant all of a sudden
based on things we've always known
yes abraham lincoln was a racist we knew
that
thomas jefferson had slaves we knew that
too dr seuss was himself not very
racially enlightened by our standards
today
most adults also knew that so why
now suddenly is there this frantic rush
to cancel
all of these long dead people
well these are these efforts are often
tied to george floyd right that's what
we're
we're told we're told that floyd's death
was some sort of
awakening for the country and it led us
to re-examine
these things that we already knew but
why should it have been
in awakening i mean george floyd was a
career criminal violent felon
who died in an altercation with police
while high on lethal doses of fentanyl
the question of whether officer chauvin
is legally culpable in his death
will be settled in the courts but why
should this unfortunate case have any
larger ramifications in society
why should it prompt us to reconsider
thomas jefferson
or think differently about dr seuss
george floyd died and now we got to talk
about dr seuss what
there is no logical connection at all
especially because floyd's case
whatever else you might say about it had
nothing to do with race
there is zero evidence and zero reason
to assume that chauvin was motivated to
any extent
or in any way by racial animosity
towards george floyd
quite literally zero evidence of that
none the point is that there is no
rational logical coherent reason
why now suddenly in one big insane rush
we should be tearing down the statues
taking the names off buildings banning
these books and so on
and when everyone starts when everyone
starts all at once taking drastic and
destructive actions
based more on emotion and reason we have
a term for that
the term is mass hysteria this is mass
hysteria
prompted and cultivated by powerful
cultural forces
and fueled on an individual level by
anger rage and fear
and that's reason enough to oppose it it
is
never a good idea to go along with mass
hysteria it is
never right to give the hysterical mob
what it wants
reasonable moral and intelligent people
should resist the mob if for no other
reason
then it is a mob
like i always say with these these
things even if for some reason you don't
like dr
seuss even if you yourself have been
ahead of this particular curve and and
you know you've been saying for years
that we should cancel dr seuss
you should still stand in disagreement
and opposition to
the mob even though they're saying what
you agree with and have always said
you should oppose them because they are
a mob
and they're not doing any of this for
any good reason at all it is all
anger hate fear cowardice that is it
second point dr seuss lived a hundred
years ago he was born
at the start of the 20th century so he
lived over 100 years ago
um did he have problematic views
well i don't even have to look it up on
wikipedia to answer that question
yeah of course he did he lived 100 years
ago
every single human on earth 100 years
ago had views that would be considered
problematic by our standards today
every single one with no exception
the vast majority of people who have
lived on the planet for the vast
majority of human history
believed things that supposedly
enlighten people in modern western
culture
would find abhorrent today in fact most
of the people currently living on earth
hold such views
and most of the rest of the people will
become will will be considered backwards
bigots by the standards of the people
living on earth 50 years from now so
it's perfectly valid and worthwhile to
examine
what our ancestors got wrong and what
they got right and really we might want
to spend more time on the
what they got right part of that
equation because they got a lot right
but it's totally absurd to broadly
condemn everyone in history for
committing the crime of being born
before
us every civilization has its moral
blind spots every single one now you may
think
that we have none of our own or that our
blind spots aren't as bad
but you see that's why we call them
blind spots because you don't see them
or understand them fully they're blind
spots
chronological snobbery as c.s lewis
described it means that the present
generation
always thinks that it is the only
generation to have
the only enlightened generation to have
ever lived
now lewis made that observation about
his own generation
and now sort of proving his point we
condemn him
and his generational peers as bigots
barely more ethically advanced than
cavemen
this is all driven by stupidity and
arrogance
and so we have two choices
we can see it for what it is and try to
stop the madness
or we can cancel everybody and then
ourselves because
if we don't stop the madness that's
where this is headed
now let's get to five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from bambi you know
when starting a business
hr issues that's the thing that can
really kill you i hear this from
business owners all the time
that hr issues that's that's what it
really comes down to you got wrongful
termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations all this kind of red tape
and hr manager salaries aren't cheap
an average of seventy thousand dollars a
year bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was
created specifically to solve this
problem for small businesses
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy and maintain your compliance
all for just 99 a month with bambi you
can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest
asset uh your dedicated hr manager is
available by phone email real time chat
they're always on call for you
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
and they're going to take this thing it
was a big hassle big problem they make
it a big strength now for your company
month to month no hidden fees cancel any
time
you didn't start your business because
you wanted to spend time on hr
compliance so this is why you need to go
to bambi.com
walsh right now to schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.com
walsh spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh well on the subject
of
madness i did want to mention this just
right off the top um
a tweet from the account breaking 911 it
says just in
2021's cpac's quote nazi stage was
designed by
design foundry which is a company that
has worked for biden and msnbc
98 of the company's political donations
have gone to democrat candidates
so i don't know uh if these if this is a
nazi company
making nazi stages uh we we
we these are new questions that that now
that now need to be answered
why was joe biden why are the democrats
working with a nazi company
why are they accepting donations from
nazi oh well because they're not a nazi
company they just it's
it was simply a stage that looked like
any other stage
nothing suspicious or weird about it and
if you fell for the um
the nazi stage hoax then you are
i cannot emphasize enough extremely
extremely stupid
all right um number one fbi director
chris
wray who is uh really terrible and bad
at his job
was testifying in front of the senate
judiciary committee
uh when he was asked about the cause
of uh the cause of death for officer
brian siknik though we've we've
talked about this issue on the show
several times that we know that officer
siknik was was at the riots on january 6
and then he died not at the riots but
later on hours many hours several hours
later
uh and and uh the the death has always
been tied to the rides we've always been
told by the media
and originally even by the police they
said that oh he died from injuries
but we've never been told anything else
about it like what exactly were the
injuries
what happened how did he actually die
we've never officially been told that
but now the fbi director was uh
testifying was asked this question and
here's what he said
there's been conflicting reports about
his cause of death
have you determined the exact cause of
death
and is there a homicide investigation
uh so i'll take the last part of your
question first there is an ongoing
investigation
into his death i have to be careful at
this age because it's ongoing
not to get out in front of it but i
certainly understand
and respect and appreciate the the keen
interest
in what happened to him after all he was
here protecting all of you
and as soon as there are information
that we can appropriately share
we want to be able to do that but at the
moment the investigation is still
ongoing
so does that mean since the
investigation going on
you have not determined the exact cause
of the death
uh that means we can't yet disclose a
cause of death
at this stage but you have determined
the cause of that i didn't say that
we're not at a point where we can
disclose
uh or confirm the cause of death this
this guy is such a snake
i mean all of these there is no good
reason you could tell from that answer
that yes they know the cause of death
if they didn't know the cause of death
he would have said well we haven't
determined it
which would be really strange that they
haven't determined it
as far as i know officer stiknick was i
believe he was cremated wasn't he
um so if they still hadn't figured out
cause death or anything
you know it'd be strange that that
happened so quickly but um
regardless no he he was asked do you
know the cause of death or do
he says oh we want the school we can't
disclose it right now okay so you know
you know we've already we've already
heard unofficial reports that he died of
a stroke
that's from anonymous law enforcement
sources
and that's certainly based on based on
what little we know that seems like
that's
probably something like that is what
happened
but he won't tell us could there be any
good reason
not to tell us could there be any
really valid honest reason to to not
tell us
what is this a national security
situation how could it possibly be
no they're not telling us i could only
we because we're not being given
this really basic information there's no
conceivable reason not to give it to us
we can only speculate
and part of my speculation here is that
um it would seem like officer signing
was not at all killed by a rider there's
there's just no connection between any
rioter and officer sicknick's death
and they don't want to tell us that
because it's embarrassing to the media
uh who who for for weeks and months now
has been has been
claiming with no evidence that there is
a connection
and the democrats and during the
impeachment proceedings
they're up there talking about brian
sicknick's death as if uh as if they
knew that that he was killed by a rioter
and they don't want to tell us that for
political reasons
now meanwhile senator dick durbin
uh during this this hearing decided to
try to explain
why antifa is not nearly as big a threat
as the people who rioted one time in dc
two months ago
i appreciate at least that he's
attempting because usually
the left and the democrats they simply
ignore this point about antifa and blm
and all the rioting that they do
and have done continue to do in fact but
here at least he's trying to offer some
sort of justification
and here's what he comes up with i
joined my republican colleagues
unequivocally in condemning left-wing
violence
but let's stop pretending that the
threat of antifa
is equivalent to the white supremacist
threat
vandalizing a federal courthouse in
portland is a crime
it should be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law but it is not
equivalent
to a violent attempt to overturn the
results of elections
nor is it equivalent to mass shootings
targeting minority communities
this false equivalency is an insult to
the brave police officers
who were injured or lost their lives on
january 6
as well as dozens of others who've been
murdered in white supremacist
attacks we need to be abundantly clear
clear
that the white supremacists and other
extremists are the most significant
domestic terrorism threat facing the
united states today
i hope everyone in this room can look at
the facts and acknowledge this
and we can come together on a bipartisan
basis
to defeat this threat we're going to
move past the fact that it sounded like
you said um
abundantly queer there and we're going
we're going to move past it and
we're not going to we're not going to
focus on that part of it uh coming from
a democratic center but
uh you know what's what's an insult he
says it's an insult to the to the police
officers well what's an insult is that
you're using
you and the other democrats are
callously using
officer sicknick's death as a pawn
as a uh as a as a political chip
that you're throwing down on the table
you know you're using it as a prop
that's what's insulting
it's also insulting to all of the many
thousands of victims of antifa and blm
riding across the country over the
summer
people had their businesses burned down
their houses burned down people who were
killed
assaulted they're
terrorized in their neighborhoods
cancer-stricken children at cancer
centers
no it's insulting that you're ignoring
them and you're boiling all of that down
to
uh vandalism of a courthouse
all of that everything that you watched
happen over the summer you didn't really
see anything none of that actually
happened
you're you're imagining things it all
all of that was was was really
uh vandalism of one single courthouse
i mean forget about the forget about the
police station that was invaded
and burned to the ground sending police
officers fleeing for their lives
forget about that you know that didn't
happen either none of these things
happened it was all
uh simply vandalism of a courthouse
and yeah you're right if if you're
comparing
um the simple vandalism of a courthouse
by some some crazy kids you comparing
that to what happened on january 6th and
the thing that happened january 6 is a
lot worse
unfortunately uh dick durbin is
inventing that he's he's
he has created his own version of the
antifa riots
that's not the reality even the
so-called vandalism
no they were trying to burn it down they
were shooting like fireworks at it
this was a siege that lasted for weeks
on end
it's a lot more than graffiti even to
that courthouse
but of course the issue is not just the
courthouse
and if you were to to to you know
i say that at least dick durbin made
some attempt to um
explain why january 6 was worse than the
blm writing
whereas most democrats will ignore the
question
but he didn't really make any attempts
at all when you listen to it because
he's not acknowledging what actually
happened
and and by the way uh
trying to overturn the results of the
election was there ever any chance of
that happening
was there ever any even the slightest
threat of that happening
um all right let's move on to number two
here camala harris
still has not commented on the andrew
cuomo scandal
and uh and that's you know an issue
because she had plenty to say of course
about
brett kavanaugh about donald trump's
sexual harassment accusers and so on
she was one of the big believe all women
people
and she hasn't said anything about the
sexual harassment claims against andrew
cuomo jen
uh pasaki was asked about that and and
here's what she said
vice president kamala harris was one of
the most vocal critics of justice brett
kavanaugh
of senator al franken when they faced
similar allegations
she said repeatedly i believe them
the women but she hasn't said anything
about the three women who are accusing
governor andrew cuomo and now this
third accuser anna rouche she actually
worked
for the biden harris campaign so at what
point
is the first female vice president going
to say something about this
well i i know that's how the the vice
president continues to feel
and uh the benefit of doing a briefing
every day is that i can certainly speak
on behalf of the president and the vice
president and so let me reiterate that
they both believe that every woman
coming forward should be heard
should be treated with dignity and
treated with respect
as you all know the new york attorney
general will oversee an independent
investigation
with subpoena power and the governor's
office said he will fully cooperate and
we certainly
support that moving forward but as you
know it's one thing to hear it
from you and it's appreciated but it's
another thing to hear it
from the vice president or the president
himself can we expect to hear
from either of them on this topic
anytime soon well again i'm speaking on
their behalf that's how they feel
uh they're personally both view this as
a
situation where uh bo all of the women
coming forward
should be treated with dignity and
respect and should have their voices
heard
uh and that's uh the representation of
their points of view
okay sure now we have to we have to
clarify again to stipulate
that uh that that of course uh every
time this comes up we have to say that
this is not the real andrew cuomo
scandal uh this is not even the real
interest the andrew cuomo scandal that
we primarily need to hear camilla harris
talking about
um or or condemning the real scandal
is are the policies that he put in place
that led to the
deaths of thousands of elderly people in
his state that's the real scandal
not the fact that he you know touched a
woman's cheek and flirted with some
women
on the job that's inappropriate behavior
uh as opposed to
killing lots of people so not the real
scandal but
as far as that goes you notice this
shift pretty obvious it's not a very
nuanced shift so i'm sure anyone can
notice it
but you notice the shift that the
democrats do
now because originally she said she said
well
we believe that all women should be
treated with dignity and respect
and they should be heard so any woman
who has an accusation we should treat
them with respect and they should be
heard
that's what she says now which obviously
yeah we all agree
we can all agree in principle in theory
treat people with respect
if someone has a a claim and accusation
we'll hear it let's let's listen
but that's not what they said in the
past what they said in the past was
believe all women there is a big
difference
i'm sure you could probably spot between
hear
all women and believe all women
pretty big difference and
so they're they're making that that
little subtle adjustment and hoping we
don't notice
well it's basically the same thing no
it's not at all
because our point all along and when i
say our i mean
the rational people um and increasingly
that is really the real dividing line in
american culture now it's irrational
people versus irrational people
but our point all along was yeah we'll
hear everybody
uh we'll hear her you know if someone
has a claim we'll listen to you
what is it but we're not gonna believe
it
simply because we heard it the believing
part requires
reasons evidence
that's that's where that comes in
all right number three governor abbott
of texas uh had a big announcement
yesterday and first we'll
play the announcement then we'll talk
about the reaction to it here he is
so today i'm issuing a new
executive order that rescinds most of
the earlier executive orders
effective next wednesday all businesses
of any type are allowed to open
100 percent
[Applause]
that includes any type of entity in
texas
also i am ending the statewide
mass mandate yeah that's and of course
the left is
reacting as you would expect them to uh
with that um accusing governor abbott of
being the one who's gonna be responsible
for for thousands of deaths and
this is an act of mass murder and so on
and so forth
and so we knew we would get that
reaction that's one thing
me i'm a little bit more annoyed and
disturbed by
many conservatives and you know
residents of texas who
you heard even there in the reaction
applauding
yeah go texas go go governor abbott
thank you so much
doing it the right way governor
yeah it's it's cool that the
restrictions are being lifted don't get
me wrong
that's great but let's not make the
mistake
of um when a when a a public official
when a politician
lifts these restrictions let's not make
the mistake of greeting them as
liberators
our liberators when they are lifting
restrictions
that they put in place and should not
have been there to begin with
so now they are reversing a bad
thing that they did so
we could be happy about that obviously
but let's not applaud them you don't
deserve applause for that at all
you should apologize actually
because the businesses that were
destroyed in the meantime they're still
destroyed
even if you give them two thousand
dollars they're still going to be
destroyed
so there's not really an applause
situation this is it's about time
and now there needs to be more
accountability
so let's not let's not applaud that
let's certainly not give governor abbott
any credit
um and uh you know
it it it's it's a it's a similar kind of
attitude
that i talk about during during during
tax season
when people start getting their refunds
and they you know they
they're so grateful to the government
for giving them a refund
it's like no that's your own money that
the government took and took too much of
your money they shouldn't have taken
that much and they did
and now they're just giving back to you
what is yours
don't be grateful to them for that
they'll be grateful to the governor for
taking off chains
that never should have been on you to
begin with um
meanwhile joe biden was uh was was
was talking about what it'll take to get
back to normal this is the
big six million dollar question and uh
when will we get back to normal
and every time he's asked that question
the the answer is like goes back a
little bit so
at first it was 100 days and we moved it
back and here's what he's saying now
i've been cautioned not to give an
answer to that because we don't know for
sure
but my hope is by this time next year
we're going to be back to normal
before that my hope but again it depends
upon if people continue
continue to be smart
and understand that we still can have
significant losses
there's a lot we have to do yet so thank
[Music]
you
yes i did what did you learn a lot
that was that's very specific what i
learned a lot
um so this time next
year i think that's the first time we've
heard at least that from joe biden
personally originally it was 100 days
any any intelligent person knew that it
was not really going to be 100 days and
now he's saying
this time next year all right number
four
from the daily wire it says california's
assembly is slated to consider a new
bill requiring department store
children's sections to be largely gender
neutral in order to combat prejudice and
judgment
against gender non-conforming children
political reported earlier this week
large retailers that sell toys clothes
and other
children's items in california would
have to devote floor space to
merchandise marketed to both boys and
girls under a new bill
stores will be able to sell the same
products they do now as long as they
maintain
some areas where shoppers can find all
toys or clothes regardless of
gender-based marketing
under the new build now all this does
all this accomplishes
obviously is making it harder and more
annoying for parents to shop for toys
which is already an annoying thing to do
especially if you
if you make the mistake of buying toys
with kid when you have kids with you
and i've been dumb enough to do that on
more than one occasion
all you're doing is making it more
difficult for a parent
to find the toy that the kid actually
wants
because no matter what what else we're
told the reality is
the majority of kids the majority of
boys prefer
toys that are associated with boys and
the majority of girls
prefer the more girlish toys
you know most of the time girls are
going for the dolls and the pink stuff
and everything boys are going for the
trucks and superheroes yeah there's
crossover of course there is
but that's the exception to the rule
vast majority of boys and girls they
want the toy that's what they want
they're not conditioned that way that's
just what they want
because that those toys it's not it's
not arbitrary those toys
um speak to something innate inherent
within them
why do little girls like dolls well
because even little girls have
that that kind of burgeoning maternal
instinct
that boys by and large don't have
most boys if you tried with all your
might
to condition them to like dolls they
still wouldn't because they don't
now you know my sons they'll they'll
play with dolls because they're gonna
have
the dolls fighting each other they're
gonna like rip a doll's head off they're
gonna do that kind of thing
they're gonna have spider-man you know
they have the doll then they got the
small spider-man figure the doll is kind
of like a a
baby godzilla going through the city
spider-man's battle like that's how they
play with dolls
um whereas my daughter she's gonna pick
up the doll
brush its hair pretend to feed it put
all
get all the nice outfits and dress the
doll she that's what she does
it's not conditioning that's that's
inherent
that's an eight and i've i've had a
a somewhat unique view of this um as a
parent of boy girl twins
so our first kids boy and a girl twins
um they had access to all the same toys
you know we we had a toy toy room in the
house the house that we lived in at the
time when they were born
and for the first few years of our life
we had a toy room we had all the toys
and
you know most of the time the toy room
is an absolute disaster it's like a
tornado
was in there and the toys are strewn all
over the place
um and it's not like when i when you
bring your little two-year-old boy and
girl
into the uh into the playroom it's not
you're not saying to them now those are
your toys as a boy
i better not catch you touching that
doll over there son even i don't do that
surprisingly now you bring the kids to
the toy room you say have at it
go crazy and what do they do even at the
age of two
they gravitate right towards their
gender-specific toys
with no guidance or instruction from the
parents
isn't that a coincidence is it such a
coincidence that
almost every child on earth seems to do
that
all right um finally number five here
amazon has tweaked the logo for its
smartphone app because people thought
that that the the other logo looked like
hitler
and so it's a it's a
this one's just hilarious i have to say
uh
in in the in the original smartphone app
logo you've got
the the arrow thing that looks like the
the
the smiley face the mouth then you've
got something there that looks kind of
like
i guess the hitler mustache and they had
to go back and change it
and this what i have to say yeah i can
kind of see it
obviously we know the left they're
they're finding hitler everywhere they
look they're finding nazis everywhere
they look
on that one yeah i can kind of see i can
see hitler there
i'm not offended by it it's hilarious
but i guess i won't blame amazon for
making the changes there
all right let's move now to reading the
comments um
this is from mr s
says remember kids the slippery slope
fallacy isn't a fallacy whatsoever
that's exactly right i keep saying this
till i'm blue in the face that
there is no such thing as the slippery
slope fallacy
there are slippery slope arguments that
are made fallaciously
there are bad versions of the slippery
slope argument
there are people arguing that something
is a slippery slope and it really isn't
so that would be a fallacious slippery
slope argument
but the slippery slope argument in and
of itself is not a fallacy at all
it is meant to do is is to demonstrate
how this thing
will lead to another thing and then lead
to another thing
and the reason that you're doing that is
to
to try to try to to point out the
logical flaws
in this course of action
uh so yes thank you thank you for that
vladimir putin
username apparently a big fan of the
show uh says
i guess it wouldn't be a big surprise to
the left says mr walsh what is the best
board game
and why is it battleship battleship
is the best board game what are you
eight years old
no the best board game is uh settlers of
catan
if you haven't played that game that's
also probably the nerdiest board game
which is which maybe is why i like it
but that's the best one without it
without a question question uh jacob
bauer says
matt who would win in a fight a gorilla
or a uh or a grizzly bear obviously a
gorilla
um they got a lot more dexterity you
know they're much more made for for
fighting
than our grizzly bears um
and finally what else we have here
benjamin says matt if you can't wrap
your head around
watching people play video games what's
the difference between
twitch and sports i got a lot of
comments and messages and even some
emails about this
um because i said that i i think this is
widely known by now i'm not a video game
fan personally
but also this this whole idea of people
sitting down
i guess on twitch and watching other
people play video games
is really hard for me to wrap my head
around i have to say
and this is a common response it's well
it's no different than watching
different than watching sports
here's the key difference to me benjamin
when you're watching sports
those are people actually doing that
you see what i'm saying so you're you're
seeing
athleticism feats of of
strength and agility and all of that
on display from from real humans not
avatars on a screen so that
i guess i can't do any more to explain
the difference um
that's all i got if that's not enough to
convince you then i got nothing
i want to tell you about a new sponsor
on the show we're really excited about
openfit openfit is a simple streaming
service that allows you to work out from
the comfort of your own home in as
little as 10 minutes a day
what makes it different is that it
offers live classes for some of the most
famous trainers in the world who can
give you personal feedback in real time
it's absolutely invaluable for that
reason you could take a ton of different
classes from beginner
to advanced including strength training
cardio pilates yoga uh even meditation
i'm probably not going to be taking the
yoga but
but many other great things as well your
trainers are there to keep you motivated
and give you direction to help you
improve your form plus it's the best
deal in fitness you get a full year of
personal training classes for about
the cost of one in-person training class
by turning your camera on the trainer
can see you you can interact with each
other
and you don't even have to leave the
comfort of your home you know i've been
using openfit
looking for gyms around here decided to
use this and the great thing is that
we talk about 10 minutes a day even if
you don't it takes away all excuses so
you feel like well i don't have time to
go to the gym
yeah but you still got 10 minutes 20
minutes to turn on uh
to go an open fit stream this and take
care of fitness for the day
and sometimes that's all it takes it's
just that little bit of commitment open
fit has changed the way that i work out
right now
my listeners can get a free 14-day trial
membership to open fit when you text
walsh to 50 50 50. and if you decide to
keep the service
which i'm sure you will the entire year
is only 96 it truly is the best deal in
fitness
you'll get full access to open fit all
the workouts in a nutrition guide
totally free for 14 days just text
walsh to 50 50 50. standard message and
data rates may apply
also many crazy leftist theories and in
some cases outright lies out there need
to be called out for what they are and
that's what ben shapiro does every day
on the daily wire and that's what he's
doing especially with the new show
debunked every friday
ben exposes popular fallacies reported
by leftist activists and politicians
with short mini documentaries that
entertain
keep you informed uh give you equip you
with knowledge so that you can go out
there
and maybe do some debunking of your own
in the first episode released last
friday ben debunks minimum wage
you've heard about all the arguments for
minimum wage well ben
tears all those apart in 15 minutes
debunked is now available to daily wire
members exclusively
if you're not a member yet go to
dailywire.com subscribe and use code
debunked to get 25
off your new membership and stay tuned
for this friday's episode where ben will
break down
unions don't want to miss that go sign
up code debunked
25 off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel another
cable news doctor these people have
of course been a scourge over the past
year as thousands of them
feels like thousands anyway have been
hired to sit in front of cameras and
offer sweeping public policy
recommendations
as if their medical degree has made them
not only experts in medicine but in
literally all other facets of human
human existence and this trend is not
likely to go away just because covet is
receding
and that brings us to dr paul offit he's
a member of the fda advisory committee
and director of the vaccine education
center at the children's hospital of
philadelphia
and he's been on cable news quite often
offering his um
prognostications and instructions most
recently he went on cnn and discussed
the question of whether
masking and social distancing should now
become a permanent part of our lives
you'll never believe what he said
actually you'll totally
believe it probably already know what it
is but here's the clip anyway
as we figure out what flu strains have
been circulating in places like
australia
or south america which sort of predicts
what what strains are likely to come
into our
our country there's been so little flu
in those two areas i think it's going to
be hard for us
to try and figure out what flu strains
to pick but you're right it's if we mask
in social distance every winter we will
see a dramatic reduction in flu which
usually causes
hundreds of thousands of
hospitalizations and tens of thousands
of deaths i wonder whether that would be
will be the lesson
from this wear masks every winter
yeah sadly this idea is not nearly as
unpopular as you want it to be a
significant number of people on social
media from what i've seen have already
made plans to wear their masks
every winter or even just every season
every year forever
pulling one at random here um this is
michael david smith who works in sports
media
and he made this announcement he said i
expect to wear a mask every winter for
the rest of my life
the flu is nowhere near as bad as cove
19 but it still kills thousands of
americans every year and wearing masks
dramatically reduces the spread it's a
tiny individual sacrifice for such a
major benefit to society
and he's far from alone um and it was
always going to be this way
some of us such as yours truly argued
from the beginning that that
all of the reasons given for wearing the
mask during covid
would apply just as much to flu season
or to the prevention of many other
communicable diseases
if it's such a small sacrifice if it's
the safest thing to do
if we're doing it for others and not for
ourselves if it prevents viruses and
germs et cetera et cetera et cetera
then all of those reasons still apply
whether covet is an issue or not
if you say that masks uh save whatever
arbitrary number of lives from covid
then they would also save whatever
arbitrary number of lives from the flu
and other illnesses even if the second
arbitrary number is smaller
those are still human lives that have
been saved supposedly hypothetically
but of course those of us who made this
point who observed how the masking
mandates set a precedent
which is never going to go away we were
called crazy in fact we were accused of
making a slippery slope argument which
we were and we were right
somehow we were labeled the paranoid
lunatics for saying this us
you know not the people wearing two
masks and a visor to walk out of their
houses and check the mailbox
but now the same people who called us
crazy for making that argument
are advocating the very thing that we
predicted they would advocate
so it goes so it always goes
but here's the thing yes obviously if
you stay away from other human beings if
you ban
large gatherings if you muzzle yourself
when you leave your house
it's going to decrease the chances that
you contract any number of viruses
it also seems like it might weaken your
immune system to a catastrophic extent
but putting that aside yes of course
staying away from people
covering your face like a leper all of
that will have the effect of potentially
warding off certain illnesses
but here that's another thing that we
already knew going back to the point we
made in the opening
monologue we knew that already that
isn't news
that isn't a recent discovery we always
knew that if we wanted to
during flu season we could reduce cases
by shutting everything down wearing the
masks and all of that
who didn't know that who exactly is just
learning this now
nobody we all knew it yet we didn't do
it
or even seriously consider doing it and
nobody advocated for it
not because we didn't understand the
science but because we judged it as not
worth the trade-off
we until this past year we all believe
that living a normal human life
was worth the risk now many of us don't
think that anymore
but those who have changed their minds
cannot say they're doing it based on the
science
because again this is not new data
there's no new scientific data
they're doing it because their
priorities changed
so the question is whether their
priorities changed for the better or the
worse
and i say for the worse i think we were
right before
we were right a year ago two years ago
all of the years until this past one
because back then if i had gone out and
said if i had said to you back then
listen let's shut society down at least
four months out of every year
um wear masks masks avoid strangers
don't see your friends don't see your
family
treat everybody like they're radioactive
and let's do this so that we don't get
the flu
let's do this every single year so that
we don't get the flu
if i had said that at any point prior to
the past 12 months
everybody would have laughed at me not
because i would have been wrong about
the science but because my priorities
would have been seen as
wildly out of whack yes there's
obviously a risk in going out into
society and interacting with people
there's a risk in going to a party with
your friends and family there's a risk
in going to a crowded bar to watch the
game with
other people in your community there's a
risk in speaking to another person face
to face with no mask
so you can see each other and hear each
other there's a risk in breathing fresh
air
but it's worth the risk it's worth the
risk because this is life this is what
living means
if you give up all of the things that
make life worthwhile enjoyable
meaningful
just to extend your life what's the
point what's the point of making life
miserable just so that you can live your
miserable miserable life for longer
is it crazy to say that speaking to
another person face to face that
breathing fresh air when you walk down
the street
is so important that we should be
willing to risk death to do it
nobody thought it was crazy until now
everybody thought the opposite claim was
crazy
see i think we had it right before we
were right the first time
yes it is worth it it is worth it to
risk
death just to breathe fresh air
it is worth it is worth risking
illness and death just so that we can go
out into society
and see other people's faces yeah
i believe that because that's human life
these are the things that make it human
life and make it worth living
and that's why dr offit and everybody
advocating for permanent masking
is of course canceled
and we'll leave it there today thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy
boering
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel ledovsky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show six dr
seuss books are removed from circulation
and liberals make excuses for the
newfangled book burning that's today on
the ben shapiro show give it a listen